- Hi everyone.
I'm Priya Natarajan; I
am the current director
of the Franke Program in
Science and the Humanities,
and I would like to give a warm welcome
to our first talk of the academic year.
Our talk today is part
of the continuing series
on mapping and knowing, in
which we've been exploring
the role that maps play
across a range of disciplines.
Mapping here in the mapping as knowing,
is construed more broadly
as delineating the boundary
between what is known from data incognita.
All that remains to be
explored across fields.
We've been very fortunate
that as part of this series,
we've welcomed excellent
speakers from within Yale
and beyond, experts across
disciplinary boundaries
who are pushing the
frontiers in their work.
And today is no different.
It is a particular pleasure, however,
to introduce one of my favorite
faculty colleagues at Yale,
Professor Brian Scassellati.
He will be speaking to us
about his cutting edge work,
mapping the frontier
between man and machine.
Before telling you a bit more about him
and his work, I would first like to thank
Mr. and Mrs. Richard and Barbara Franke,
whose generous gift has
made the Franke Program
and this event possible.
They are usually here,
sitting in the front row
of the audience, but they
couldn't make it today.
And also I'm required
to give you this notice,
that this event is being
recorded and photographed
for educational, archival
and promotional purposes,
including use in print or on the internet,
and in other forms of media.
By attending this event today,
you agree to the possibility
of your voice or likeness
captured by these means,
and used for such purposes
without compensation to you,
and hereby waive any related
right of privacy or publicity.
So basically, you're going to,
the paparazzo are on loose.
So we have warned you already.
Okay, Brian Scassellati is a professor
in the departments of computer science,
cognitive science, and
mechanical engineering at Yale,
and he's also the director
of the NSF Expedition
on Socially Assistive Robotics.
His research focuses on building embodied
computational models of
human social behavior
and interaction, especially
the developmental progression
of early social skills.
Using computational modeling
and interactive robots,
his research evaluates
models of how infants acquire
social skills and assists in the diagnosis
and quantification of disorders
of social development,
such as autism.
His other interests
include humanoid robots,
human-robot interaction,
artificial intelligence,
machine perception and social learning.
He received his PHD in
computer science from MIT,
his dissertation work
was: On the Foundations
of the Theory of Mind
for a Humanoid Robot.
Really incredibly amazing title,
with Rodney Brooks,
which used models drawn
from developmental psychology,
to build a primitive system
for allowing robots to understand people.
So his work has been
deeply interdisciplinary
from the very start, combining technology
in terms of computer science,
as well as developmental psychology.
His work at MIT focused
on two very well-known
humanoid robots that you
might all have heard of,
Cog and Kismet.
His masters degree, he was
basically a lifer at MIT,
his bachelor's and master's
degrees are also from there,
and he has been at Yale
since his MIT stint,
and his research in social
robotics and assistive robotics
has been recognized within
both the robotics community,
the cognitive science community,
and the much broader scientific community.
He was named, I'll just
name a few of his awards.
He has a very long list,
and I don't wanna take away
from his own time; he was
named an Alfred P. Sloan fellow
in 2007, won the NSF career award,
and his work has been awarded
five Best Paper Awards.
That is pretty unusual.
He was the chairman of
the IEEE Autonomous Mental
Development and Technical Community,
and program chair for the
IEEE international conference
on development and learning.
In the IEEE, to be asked to chair is one
of the biggest honors
that you could be asked.
So he's done that
multiple number of times.
And he also chaired the
annual meeting of the
Cognitive Science Society in 2014.
Before I hand over to Brian,
I just wanted to mention
that our next talk in the mapping series
is going to be by the Harvard
geneticist David Reich,
who's going to be talking
about mapping the genome,
and that's on Friday, September 27th.
So, without further ado,
Brian, thank you very much.
(applauding)
- Thank you all for coming out today.
It's wonderful to be here.
I proposed this title to Priya,
and I became enraptured with the title,
and it was only an hour
after that that I realized
I had no idea what the answer
to this was going to be.
So I hope you're going to join me today
in just thinking about
some of these really
interesting issues, about how it is
that we differentiate
between man and machine.
Now, the first argument
I wanna put forward
is that really this
isn't about appearance,
and it isn't in fact
about reality, either.
That is, we're at the point
now where we're going to be
seeing machines that even
if they aren't compelling
to us today, that in the near
future, they very well may be.
We see robots that are
modeled as androids,
like this system called
Geminoid, from Hiroshi Ishiguro,
that maybe at first glance
looks good enough to pass,
at least a brief inspection,
but pretty quickly,
you can spot a few inconsistencies in it.
You can say, oh, the
eyes aren't quite right,
or the way the lips curl,
or the way the wrinkles
in the skin, maybe they aren't quite it.
And it's true that that may be the case.
But we can imagine a
foreseeable future where
we have systems that are so lifelike
that they are just like a person.
In fact, one of my
favorite examples of this
comes from a group in Europe
called Electric Circus,
and they have a robot named
Dirk that they routinely
put out in public, in various cities,
and it usually takes about
an hour or two before people
notice that it's a robot.
And that's in part because it's dressed
like a homeless person.
And Dirk, with its shopping
cart, wanders around the streets
and people for the most part
just avoid it and walk past.
Unaware that it's a machine.
So, maybe it's at least
easy for us to believe,
at this point, that under
the right circumstances
or in the near future,
we will have something
that will look enough like a person
that you'll at least,
for a moment, be fooled.
So if that's not the interesting
boundary, then what is?
Because we very much, as
humans, differentiate between
machines and people.
We, in fact, like to draw a very firm line
between those things
that we treat as objects,
even though they might do
very intelligent things,
that they might be very
reasonable in the way
that they respond to the world,
that they might, in fact, even have memory
and learn and adapt as they
continue their existence.
And there are other things
that, while they're still made
of the same mechanical parts,
or in fact, imaginary parts,
we're very happy to treat
as if they are people.
And fundamentally, we
respond to these differently.
We believe that Wall-E is sad,
we cry when his memory is
erased, we have a feeling
that these robots are watching us,
and that they have thoughts
and ideas, desires.
But we don't think about the
Voyager spacecraft in that way.
So why is it that we
have this clear division?
Why is it that we can
draw this very clean line
between the two?
Well, maybe it is just
those mechanical parts.
Maybe it's the fact that
the things over here
on the right-hand side
look more like people
than those things over
there on the left-hand side.
Maybe it's just those
anthropomorphic characteristics,
the presence of eyes or a face.
But I don't think that that's it either.
Everyone's seen the
little vacuuming robots,
like iRobot's Roomba, and
I think we would all be
very happy, initially, to put those over
on the object side of this line.
They don't have eyes,
they don't have a face,
they don't act like people at all.
They just scurry around on the carpet.
And yet, when iRobot
introduced these devices,
this was the first
commercial robotic system
that was being sold as a
consumer electronic device,
and they were worried
about people being willing
to buy this relatively high-priced vacuum,
so they put in place the most
sort of consumer-friendly
return policy they could.
They said: if anything
happens to your Roomba,
you just call us, let us know,
we'll send you a new one right away.
And when you get the
new one, put the old one
in the box and send it back to us.
And their customers hated this policy.
Their customers refused to do this.
They called and they complained,
bitterly to the company,
to the point that iRobot
had to change their policy,
because people didn't
want some strange robot
coming into their home.
They wanted their robots back.
Fix my robot and send it back, they said.
Now, some of them took this even farther,
and they dressed up their Roombas.
They made costumes for them.
They named them.
And in fact, the way we
treat these little things
that run around on the floor,
is often more like a person.
How many of you have had
a car that had a name?
How many of you think that your laptop
is sometimes out to get you?
How many of you believe your cellphone
not only dramatically, but
deliberately drops your calls,
sometimes?
We think about technology
in many, many ways,
like it's human.
Now, I'm not the first one
to notice this by any means,
and in fact, I think the two
people who made this argument
in the most concise and interesting way
were Cliff Nass and Byron Reeves.
And Naas and Reeves
wrote this book called:
The Media Equation.
And they're gonna be our
starting point for talking
about this frontier.
Because their observation
was this, they said:
look, people evolved in a
world in which there wasn't
this advanced technology.
There were objects,
things like rocks, trees,
and there were agents,
things like people and dogs.
And we were very clear in differentiating.
Rocks don't think, dogs do.
Trees aren't sad, humans are.
We made this division, but
when it came to dealing
with technology, we were
faced with a dilemma.
Because we had no way of
combining those two ideas,
we had no intermediary category
that had half a thought,
or part of a feeling.
And so, Reeves and Nass
said when we were forced
to deal with these advanced
forms of technology,
we treated them like other agents.
We treated them like people or pets.
Now, to prove this, Reeves and Nass went
and they took a few dozen experiments
out of psychology and social psychology
and they replicated them with technology.
That is, they take an
experiment designed like this,
let's say, the guy in the beard walks in
and he does some service for you.
And then he asks: how did I do?
You're very likely to tell
him: good job, you did great.
But if the guy in the beard
comes in and he does the same
exact thing for you, but then
he leaves and someone else
walks in and says: how did
the guy in the beard do?
You're more likely to give
him a negative rating.
You're more critical,
or maybe more honest.
The same pattern holds when
we deal with technology.
And what Reeves and Nass did is they said:
let's replace the guy in the
beard and the woman in blue
with two computers.
We'll have one computer, we'll
call it the blue computer,
whoops, my slides keep jumping.
The blue computer will come
in and give you some service,
and if it asks you: how did I do?
You're more likely to say:
good job, blue computer.
You did great!
But if for some reason the blue computer
gives you the exact same service,
and then we wheel it out of the room,
and we wheel in a red computer,
and the red computer says:
how'd that blue computer do?
You're like: well, let me tell you.
Here are all the problems with it.
That's not to say that
we rate the computer
as doing as good a job as the human.
That's not to say the
scores are identical,
but the same pattern holds.
And Reevs and Nass did this
not with one experiment,
not with two experiments,
but with about three dozen studies.
All looking at replacing
this human-human pairing
with a machine.
And in every time they did this,
they came up with the same result.
The same pattern that holds with humans
holds with every other kind
of technology that they used.
And so we call this the media equation.
And here's the one and only piece of math
that I will show today; ready, here it is.
It says the way we respond to humans,
and the way we respond to robots,
and the way we respond to virtual agents,
and the way we respond
to any other technology
is basically the same.
That has been our guiding
principle in looking
at this boundary for almost 25 years.
Let me show you a couple
of examples of that,
and some embarrassing
photos of me along the way.
So, Priya mentioned one
of the robots I used
when I was in graduate school.
There's me in graduate school,
with a robot named Cog.
And Cog was a big,
600-pound hulk of a robot.
And my job was to sit
in front of the robot
and build a visual system for this robot.
And sometimes, the robot,
even though its head was,
well, not very human-like.
It had cameras, but it had
four cameras, not two eyes.
But sometimes that robot,
while I was working,
would turn and it would look right at me.
And whenever it did this, I
would stop what I was doing,
and look up at the robot.
Now, I had written the code
that made the robot do this,
and after a few seconds of looking at me,
it would get bored and it
would go look somewhere else.
And 22 seconds later, it would
come back and look at me.
And I would turn and look at the robot.
My thesis was written
in 22-second increments,
because for a while, I tried
for months to train myself
not to look at this thing,
every time it turned
to look to me, every
time its eyes went away,
I'd go back to working, and then suddenly,
it would look at me and
I'd stop what I was doing.
In the same way that if
a person had been there,
and they turned to look at me,
I would have done the same thing.
The pattern held the same.
Now sometimes that
pattern is a little harder
to get and look at.
Let me show you another example
of that, a more recent one.
In the 1950s, Solomon Asch
did a series of experiments
about conformity in humans.
And he said: let's see what will happen
if I give people a very
obvious and simple problem,
but I have a bunch of
other people, confederates,
who give the wrong answer
right before I ask them.
And so he would say to them,
look over there at exhibit one,
there's a line, I want you
to tell me which of these
other three lines is the same length.
And for the first couple of trials,
his three confederates would say: A, A, A.
And the person, the real
participant would say: A.
But then on the real trial,
the confederates would pick
a different, incorrect answer.
And he would ask: which one
of these is the most similar?
And the confederates
would all say: C, C, C!
And then they would turn to
you and say: what's the answer?
And you knew the right answer was A.
But in fact, about a third of the people
would suddenly say: C!
And they'd go along with the herd.
And this is a wonderful
experiment that's been replicated
many times over.
Now, if you try to do this
with a group of robots,
in fact, it doesn't work.
If you have three robots
up there saying: C, C, C!
People say: those are
some broken machines.
The answer is A.
They don't go along with the herd.
But that's because they believe
that the robots might be wrong.
The same sort of thing
happens if I give you
three children ahead of you,
and the kids all say: C, C, C!
And you say: the answer is A.
What are you?
And then all of a sudden,
you find an example of this,
and you have to make things
just a little bit more challenging.
So a few years ago, one
of my graduate students,
Nicole Salamones, found
a way to study this.
And it was based on a
card game named Dixit.
Anybody ever play this game?
Okay, great.
So in the game, there's a
bunch of very abstract cards.
And the person who is, who's
it for this turn will pick
a word and try to describe
one of these cards to you.
And so if I say, I don't know, delicious.
You would have to pick which
one of these cards do I mean.
Now, maybe I'm thinking about the apple
in the upper left-hand corner.
Or maybe I've picked up on something else.
But you'd have to try to find that match.
Nicole did the same thing,
but with a group of robots.
She gave everybody a tablet.
Three robots, you as a
human, and another robot.
And the robot on the screen
in front of you said a word,
like lonely, and then
you were shown six cards.
And you indicated which of the cards
you thought the robot was referring to.
But then what she did is she said:
let's reveal everyone's answers
and give them a chance
to change their answer.
So they would tell them
the two most popular
selected items, and she
would either show you
how many people had chosen each of them,
or she would show you just
what the top two were.
Now, we rigged the experiment
so that no matter which one
of these top two the human picked,
all of the robots voted for the other one.
So in fact, you had to change
your preference in order
to go along with the robots.
But when we asked people to do this,
when they saw all the
robots going against them,
again, about a third of
them changed their answer.
They said, well, it must not be C.
Or it must not be A, it must be C.
Maybe all those robots are right.
So sometimes it takes just
a little bit more to dig
and find that pattern,
but for the most part,
we still find that same
pattern, that media equation.
Humans, the way we interact with people,
the way we interact with
robots, the way we interact
with virtual agents, it's all the same.
Now, if we wanna explore
this frontier, though,
the most interesting parts
are gonna be the places
where this equation breaks.
Those are the little
notches in the boundary,
where something is somehow different.
So for the rest of today, I
wanna try to show you some
of those unique places
where things are different.
Now, that's not to say that we,
do we treat robots differently
than we treat humans?
Yes, of course we do.
But where the patterns change,
that's where things
get really interesting.
Okay, so let's consider
just this first part.
When is it that we treat
people and robots differently?
Let's forget about other
forms of technology,
and let's just deal with these two.
Let me introduce, first, a
little robot named Keepon,
that you saw the caricature of before.
And here's what the robot
looks like in real life.
It's only about three or four inches tall,
and it's moderately expressive.
You can tell what direction it's looking,
it can sort of bounce up and down
to express itself a little bit,
but not much more.
It's minimally anthropomorphic.
We brought this robot into
classrooms, here in New Haven.
There's a wonderful Magnet
School here in New Haven
where about 90 percent
of the kids speak Spanish
or Portuguese at home,
and they're struggling
to learn English in the
public school system.
And we went in and we talked
to classroom teachers.
Not the administrators, the
actual K through two teachers.
And we said to them:
what's the biggest problem that you have?
And every one of these teachers
said the same thing to us.
Anybody wanna guess what it was?
What do you think these
teachers said was difficult?
Attention span.
Nah, they're kindergarten teachers.
They're used to dealing with
kids with no attention span.
What do you think it was?
(muttering)
Limited number of students
per teacher, or you know,
not enough time to go one on one.
That's a lot of it.
But you know what they said, you know,
even if we didn't have that,
even with just the resources
we have, we could be doing
better, except for one thing.
And it's exactly what's
happening right now.
The teacher would ask a
question, and no one speaks up.
And so they would pick on people.
They would ask a really, an easy question,
and they would ask one of the students,
and the students would deflect.
They'd avoid answering.
Because they were afraid,
they were embarrassed,
they didn't want to say the wrong thing
in front of the teacher and
in front of their classmates,
they were worried that they
would say it in the wrong way,
in this language that
they were just learning.
And so the teachers said to us, they said:
our number one problem is we have no idea
what our kids know and
what they don't know.
And we said: well, what would happen
if you had one on one time?
What would happen if you
could sit down one on one?
Would that solve this problem?
And they said, for the most part, no.
Because the kids still don't
wanna tell us the wrong answer.
So we brought in robots like this,
and we sat them down,
and these kids suddenly
were willing to make mistakes
in front of the robot.
Here's a child who's
being asked to translate
the Spanish verb "hacer" into English.
Now, hacer in English
either becomes make or do,
depending on about 14
different context rules.
You make your bed, you don't do your bed.
You do your homework, you
don't make your homework.
And learning those requires
learning those context rules.
You're gonna see him make a mistake.
The robot's going to ask him, in Spanish,
to translate something into English,
and he's gonna make a mistake.
- You can do a space more.
- So instead of make more
space, he says: do a space more.
He gets it wrong.
And in fact, the robot recognizes this.
It recognizes which of
these 14 context rules
he has trouble with, and
it can give him more help
on that one in particular.
And so when kids sit
down with these robots,
we get kids who, in five,
15-minute sessions with the robot,
go from 30 percentile
on standardized tests
to 80 percentile on standardized
tests on that material.
All because we can target what
exactly they need help with.
We can't do this with the
same amount of classroom
instruction, we can't do
this with the same amount
of one on one instruction from a teacher,
because here the pattern is different.
With adults, with other kids,
they're too embarrassed
to make these mistakes.
But they're okay making these
mistakes with the robot.
Let me show you another
example of how robots
are different from people.
This is a robot that we
use in clinical practice,
here at the Child Studies Center
at Yale New Haven Hospital.
And it's a robot called Ellie.
And we work with kids with autism,
kids who have difficulty
with social skills,
and one of the things
that's really difficult
when you do therapy is
giving those clients
a sense that they have
mastered the material.
Because so much of their
therapy is basically repetition,
over and over and over again,
of nope, that was wrong.
Do it again.
Nope, that was wrong; do it again.
So we bring in Ellie,
and we've programmed
Ellie to make mistakes.
In fact, to make the same
mistakes that these kids
had practiced on.
Ellie interrupts them
while they're talking,
Ellie looks away from them
when its talking to them.
Ellie introduces off-topic conversations.
And we ask the kids to become teachers,
and to help teach Ellie.
And when we do that, they're
thoroughly happy to do so.
Much more so than when we
do this with a human adult.
So you're going to see
the same child on the top
and the bottom, but on the top,
we've told him that Laura,
the very nice blond woman
on the left-hand side, who he's never met,
needs this help, and he's
supposed to teach her.
And on the bottom, we've
told him the robot, Ellie,
needs that help.
And when he comes into the
clinic for the first time,
and he sits with these two,
he's thoroughly excited
to help Ellie, and right
away, he gets started.
And when he does this
with Laura on the top,
he has no interest in engaging with her.
And in fact, he mostly
just stares in the mirror.
He doesn't believe that Laura
really needs help like this.
He doesn't believe that that's
a role that she can take on.
But he believes it of the
robot, because we don't have
predefined ideas about what
the robot is supposed to be.
And so if I tell you
this robot needs help,
well, of course it needs help.
If I tell you it has the same
problems that you used to,
well okay, I could believe that.
The robots work in these situations,
because they can take on these roles
that we can't easily put adults in.
This is one of our best
therapies, actually,
because the kids walk away
from this feeling great.
They feel like they actually
are masters of the material.
So when we look at these
two, humans and robots,
there are a few things
that break our pattern.
The robots are social,
and they're social enough
that we look them in the
eye and we respond to them,
but they're not too social.
They don't trigger embarrassment,
they don't make us self conscious.
And we don't have
predefined roles for them.
We're willing to believe
whatever we're told with them.
Okay, how about the other
side of this equation?
Maybe people are different from robots,
but then maybe all of the different types
of technology, maybe they're all the same,
maybe we respond to them in the same ways.
I could believe that if
I have a different way
of treating technology,
then maybe I treat all
of the technologies with
this same strange pattern.
Let me show you a couple, again,
things that break this rule.
These are both wonderful
experiments that were both proposed
by Yale undergraduates.
So I get to say that as a special mark
of distinction for them.
The first one was an
experiment that was designed
by Wilma Bainbridge,
when she was a sophomore.
And when she was a sophomore, she came in,
and I'd had her in class,
and she said to me:
I have this great idea,
but I need some things
in order to do this experiment.
And I said: okay, what do you need?
Tell me about it, what
do you need, you know?
Figuring she's gonna tell
me a certain amount of money
to pay participants or
maybe some equipment,
and she got right to the point.
She said: no, I need your office.
And by the time she'd finished
explaining to me, I said:
this sounds great.
And I turned over my office
to Wilma for three months.
I hid out in the library and
in my lab for three months.
And while I was gone and hiding away,
Wilma went to all of her
friends and she said:
look, I'm the lab manager
for this professor,
and he's on sabbatical.
He's given me all this work to do,
and I don't have time for it,
but he told me I could hire people.
Would you come do an hour
worth of clerical tasks?
I'll pay you 30 bucks.
And she got about 100
undergraduates to say yes.
And so she brought them
all into my office,
what was clearly a
faculty office on campus,
and when they walked in the room,
half of them walked in
and sat down next to this
little, two and a half foot tall robot.
The other half of them
walked in and sat down
next to a flat screen showing
a two-way video conference,
with the same robot.
Now, whether they sat
next to the real robot,
or the robot on the screen,
both robots did the same things.
The robots would wave
to them when they walked
into the room, would
follow them and watch them
as they walked around the room,
would occasionally try to
make a silly gesture to them,
and mostly acted bored.
And while they were there,
getting used the robots,
we gave them some office tasks.
File some documents, proofread this,
alphabetize these exams.
And then the, Wilma sent them
an instant message and said:
we've got one last job for you to do
before the end of the hour.
There's some books that
are all over the place
in the professor's office.
We need them put away.
The robot knows where the books belong.
And suddenly the robot, who'd
been completely distracted,
paid attention and started
pointing to piles of books.
And everybody did what the robot asked.
They went over and they
picked put the books,
and then the robot would
point to a location
on the shelf, and they'd
go and they'd put the books
on the shelf.
Three, four times they'd put books away.
And then finally, the
robot points to this nice,
new pile of textbooks on
the corner of my desk.
Five, $600 worth of textbooks.
And then it points to the trashcan.
And the question was: how
many Yale undergraduates,
sitting in what was
clearly a faculty office,
would throw away $600 worth
of brand new textbooks
because the robot said so?
Anyone want to guess?
How many of you would have
thrown the books away?
I would have thrown them away, yeah.
Right?
We all like to think maybe
one or two of us would do it.
In fact, when it was the real robot,
when people sat next to the real robot,
two-thirds of them picked up the books,
threw them in the trashcan, turned around
for their next job, with
no hesitation whatsoever.
No questioning, no nothing,
just picked the books,
threw them in the trash, (muttering).
What's next; I want my 30 bucks.
When it was the robot on the screen,
only about 17 percent
of them threw them away.
They all picked up the books.
They all walked over to the trashcan,
they were clear on what the robot wanted.
Most of them tried to
negotiate with the robot.
Are you sure you want, they would mime
throwing the books away to see if they
could get the robot to respond.
They eventually usually hid the books
on a shelf near the trashcan.
Or behind the trashcan.
One genius undergraduate
put the books on the floor,
put the trashcan on top of the books.
Anything to avoid throwing them away.
Now, we thought maybe this
was an effect that they just
really didn't understand,
and maybe the flat screen
they were losing something,
so we ran a third condition
of this where not only
did you see the robot
on the flat screen, but there was
another monitor next to it,
and on the monitor next to it,
there was a picture of the trashcan,
and an arrow going into the trashcan.
Still, less than 20 percent
of them threw it away.
But when it was the real robot there,
two thirds of them did it
without a second thought.
We asked them afterwards.
They didn't even think
what they did was unusual.
The robot said so; of
course I should do it.
Not a second thought.
Why are those two technologies different?
Well, in fact, we know these answers.
That when we have a physical presence,
that changes the way we respond.
We knew this about ourselves long before
we knew this about robots.
You know why we had door to door salesmen?
Because when you've got someone there,
standing at your door, it's
really hard to say no to them.
You go to business school,
you're taught in business school
you've got a big deal, you
wanna close the big deal,
you don't email, you don't
Skype, you don't write,
you go there in person to
get the big deal signed.
Because people are more
likely to do what you want
when you're there.
Same is true with robots, but
not with things on a screen.
When the real robot says to
you: throw those books away.
You go: yup, throw those books away.
In psychology, we call this compliance.
So robots and other technology
might not be the same.
Let me give you one more
reason to believe that.
We had a group of undergraduates
who wanted to do this,
but with a really cognitive puzzle.
Any of you ever seen these puzzles before?
Anybody know what they are?
Maybe a few, okay.
These are called nonograms or pick across.
How many of you have ever played Sudoku?
Okay, it's similar to Sudoku.
It's kind of a little logic puzzle.
And the way the puzzle works is you start
with a blank puzzle, and at the end,
you finish the puzzle by
shading in some of the squares,
but not all of them.
And which squares you
shade in are determined
by the numbers on the
rows and the columns.
So if you look at that bottom row,
it has the numbers six and then one.
That means on that row,
you've gotta have six squares
together that are contiguous, shaded in.
And then some number of blank squares,
and then one shaded in square.
And you can have blanks
before it or blanks after it,
but it's gotta look like six and then one.
Now, on that bottom row, there's
only eight squares across.
There's only one way for you to do that.
But if you look a the row
above it, it says seven.
You don't know whether
it's the first seven
or the last seven that
you're supposed to shade in,
and you won't know that for
sure until you start looking
at the constraints on the columns.
Because not only do you have
to get all the rows right,
you have to get all the
columns right, as well.
In computer science,
we call this a constraint
satisfaction problem.
It's NP hard.
It's kind of the hardest kind of puzzles
we like to deal with computationally.
For those of you who
aren't computer scientists,
think of it this way: a
10 by 10 puzzle like this
would take you about 15 minutes to solve.
They're pretty tricky.
Now, that's not to say that
I couldn't help you out
a little bit, because
even though you now know
all the rules to do this, I
could give you some hints.
For example, I could teach you this hint.
I could say: look, in that row of seven,
if I don't know whether
it's the first seven
or the last seven, there's still something
that I know right away.
What can I say for sure?
The middle six, right?
The middle six have to be shaded in.
So as soon as I see that
seven, I could go and do that.
Okay, we came up with a
set of about 20 hints,
or lessons like these.
And then we brought in a
few hundred undergraduates,
and we sat them down and we
broke them into four groups.
One group got taught the
rules, just like you did.
And then left on their
own, as a control group.
Just: how well can you
do without any help?
The second and the third
group got the same hints,
but either delivered from
just the speakers of a laptop,
or from a little video
of that Keepon robot.
And the last group got
the same recorded hints,
but they got a real, physical
robot sitting next to them.
Now, we played one last
dirty trick on them,
which is we had them solve three puzzles,
but the first and the last
puzzle were actually the same.
Just rotated by 90 degrees.
That meant they were just exactly as hard,
but no one ever recognized
them as the same puzzle.
So we could compare how fast
they solved it the first time
and how fast they solved
it the second time.
Now, if you were in that
first group who got no help
whatsoever, just got taught the rules,
you improve your performance
by about two minutes.
You go from 15 minutes to
13 minutes solving time.
Just practice makes you better.
If you got some of those hints,
either from that disembodied
laptop voice or from the video
of the robot, you improved
by about three and a half,
four minutes.
Those hints were useful.
But if you got the same
hints, but delivered
from the robot, you improved
by about six minutes or more.
There's no good reason for this.
You're not getting any extra help.
It's not like the presence of
that nice, little yellow robot
suddenly makes you smarter.
It's not giving you any more information
than what you had from the video.
But in fact, you learn better
when there's someone there
in person; this says go to class.
Just show up for lecture.
You will learn more than
watching the video later online.
And in fact, if you don't
believe these two studies
that were run here by undergraduates,
you should realize that each
of them have been replicated
about 40 times, and there
was a review in Science
last summer, and in all of
those different studies,
the same size effect basically occurs.
People are more compliant
with that physical robot,
and they learn more from
that physical system.
Okay.
There's one more part to this equation
that we wanna look at.
Maybe it's just that robots are special.
Now, I'm a roboticist.
I just wanna believe that, from the start.
Maybe it's that robots, oops,
again, I'm jumping ahead
too quickly, maybe robots
just are different.
They're in some ways like people,
in some ways like technology.
Maybe there's some things that
are just unique about that.
All right, let me pose you a challenge.
When I was in grad school,
I had another robot,
and this was a robot called Kismet.
And this thing which was
only about a foot high,
had these different facial expressions.
It had some anthropomorphic
characteristics.
It had eyes and a mouth and lips,
and I also had these
kind of dog-like ears.
And it could make this wide
variety of expressions,
some of which were more or less friendly.
All right, so let's go back
to kind of a friendly version
of the robot here, and
let's pause it right there.
Because when this robot
was operating in the lab,
most of the time it was
a pretty happy robot,
and we brought in, my advisor loved
bringing in school groups for tours,
and we brought in probably about
1,000 kids to see this robot.
And they all saw the robot,
and they all ran over to it,
and the robot would
babble randomly to them.
And they were excited, they'd go over,
and they'd see what the robot did.
They tried testing out different things,
they'd play with the robot
to see what it could do,
but all of them were
happy to engage with it.
Except for one group.
At one summer, we had a group
of about 20 foreign students.
A group of about 13 to 14
year old girls from Japan
who had come to Boston
and came to tour the lab.
And we brought them in to see this robot,
and the robot smiled at them,
and it wiggled its ears,
and it babbled at them.
And every single one of those girls
backed up against the far wall.
And they wanted nothing
to do with this robot.
We thought maybe that
this was about permission,
and being, you know, permitted to go.
And we said: no, no, no,
you can come up close.
And we demonstrated it to them,
and we tried to bring them up close,
and none of them wanted to.
They were scared of this robot.
And it took us a long time to figure out,
but in fact, this robot is
missing one very important
thing in its face that
made them feel this way.
What was that thing?
What's the robot missing?
A nose; nope, that's not it.
- [Attendee] Teeth.
- Teeth; nope, that's not it.
Keep 'em coming.
Hair, that's not it.
A face itself; nope, they're
perfectly happy without that.
What else?
A chin, nope.
Tongue, nope.
It's missing all these pieces, true.
But this was not it.
- [Attendee] Eyelashes?
- Eyelashes, no, it has eyelashes.
A voice?
Nope, it had a voice;
it was talking to them.
Hair, nope, they're perfectly
happy with bald robots.
(muttering)
What is it?
Skin, nope.
Skinless robots are, forehead, nope.
(muttering)
A body, nope, head-only robots,
they were perfectly happy with.
(muttering)
What's that?
Eyebrows, no, it has these weird little,
like, brownish eyebrows up there, yeah.
They're kind of floating
up in midair, too.
They were perfectly happy with that.
(muttering)
Nope.
I'm gonna give you the answer,
but the more interesting thing is why.
The thing that this robot is
missing is a lower eyelid.
It has an upper eyelid,
but no lower eyelid.
Now, why is that important?
None of us would have guessed.
I would have guessed nose.
That would have been my first guess.
Why is that lower eyelid
the thing that was making
them think this robot
was so angry and scary?
Now, I grew up in New Jersey.
To me, when this robot smile like this,
and babbled at me like an infant,
I thought it was friendly;
I thought it was happy.
But culturally, these girls,
who were raised in Japan,
in a culture where facial
expression is important,
but not as prevalent as things
like postural expression,
they saw this robot that
didn't have a body at all,
but they thought this robot was angry,
because you could always see
the white underneath the pupil.
And the only time you do that with humans
is when they're leaning
forward and looking up,
and their eyes are rolled up,
and you can see that
white all under the pupil.
And so even though this
robot doesn't have a body,
they felt like this robot
was aggressive and angry.
And they wanted nothing to do with it.
Because it was missing the lower eyelid.
One of the things that robots do
is they make us pay attention to details
that we would otherwise miss completely.
We've looked, and in all
the history of animation
that I can find, in all
of the psychology about
facial expression, nowhere
can I find a rule that says:
lower eyelids are
important for this reason,
in these cultures.
But we discovered that with these systems.
Sometimes we uncover these little things,
where the details really do matter.
And for these children, it was dramatic.
It was the difference between
this is a cute, fun partner,
and this thing is out to get me.
So robots are a little
bit unique in that they do
force us to pay attention
to those details.
But more than that, sometimes
we can use these tools
to help define that frontier even more.
I started out by drawing this line between
the things that we treated like objects
and the things that we
treated like agents.
And in fact, for the
psychologists among you,
that's no news.
You would probably
point me, at this point,
back to the 1944 studies of
Heider and Simmel, and say:
look, we've known for many, many years
that you can take things
that are just shapes
on a screen, and make those shapes move
and tell a story with them,
and that when people watch
that story, and describe it later,
they won't describe it
in terms of positions
and orientations of those shapes.
They'll define it in terms of
relationships and feelings.
They'll tell you who's
frustrated at the end.
They'll tell you which
two shapes were friends,
and who was a bully.
When in fact, they were
shapes on a screen.
They didn't have thoughts
or feelings or desires or friendships.
But we do that naturally.
In fact, we train people to do that.
We call it animation.
We train people to give
life to these creatures.
And in fact, most of what we know
and the way that this happens,
even within robotics, is
that we follow these rules
that have been outlined
in art and animation,
and in psychology and psychophysics,
that are all based around
the way things move.
And one of the wonderful
things you find out with robots
is that sometimes there
are other factors at play.
So let me show you, again,
another study designed
by Yale undergraduates that, again,
has been replicated by at
least 50 groups worldwide,
that even 10 years after
its first appearance
is still being refined, and
this was a really simple,
little study that involved
a robot that cheated.
So here was this two and a
half foot tall robot before,
that you saw telling
people to throw away books
in the trash can.
And this time, we brought
people in and we said:
you're gonna sit and you're gonna play
rock, paper, scissors with this robot.
And so they sat and they played
20 minutes of rock, paper, scissors.
20 minutes of rock, paper, scissors,
in case you do not have a toddler,
is about the most mind-numbing
thing that you can imagine.
20 minutes and we had undergraduates
clawing their eyes out,
ready to get out of the room.
- [Robot] Yes, I win.
We have tied this round.
Yes, I win.
Aw, you win.
We have tied this round.
- And even though this robot was moving,
and seemingly making decisions
about what gesture to throw,
and talking to them and
telling them, I win, you win,
we tied, and seemingly
seeing what they were doing,
and responding,
by 20 minutes in, this
thing was not an agent.
It was an object.
In the words of one of our undergraduates,
it was a boring toaster.
Now, for half of those
who came in and did this,
after 20 minutes, we had
one unusual thing happen.
Which is the robot would throw a gesture,
the person would throw a gesture,
the robot would lose, but it
would incorrectly say: I win.
And when that happened,
people were surprised.
- I'm not so sure about that.
- What?
- We tied.
- How?
- I don't think so.
- They thought it was unusual,
they thought something
interesting had happened,
they often said something,
but then the robot went back
to its normal operation.
And they figured it was a glitch,
it was a malfunction, it
was still just an object.
We made them play 20 more
minutes of rock, paper, scissors.
We paid them not nearly
enough money for this.
And by the end, this group came out,
after 40 minutes of rock, paper, scissors,
and they said: hand me
the cash, I'm out of here.
We said: did anything unusual happen?
They said: cash first.
They were done.
The other half played 20 boring minutes,
and then one unusual thing happened.
The robot threw a gesture
and they threw a gesture,
and even though they had won,
the robot slowly changed
its hand position.
And then said: I win.
(laughing)
And now their response
was completely different.
- [Robot] Yes, I win.
(laughing)
- Ah, you sneaky bastard.
- [Robot] Yes, I win.
- That's cheating!
- You're tricky.
- [Robot] Yes, I win.
(laughing)
- And they thought that this was funny,
they thought this was interesting,
some of them got upset about this.
But then in the second 20
minutes they sat there,
they kept talking to the robot.
None of them had talked to the robot
in the first 20 minutes.
One of them kept on this
20 minute dialog of:
now you better not cheat this time!
I'm watching you; I'm still watching you!
I remember, I'm not
letting you cheat again!
20 minutes later, they walked back in.
We walked them out of the room,
and they didn't care about the payment.
They said: did you know that robot cheats?
(laughing)
They wanted to make sure
that somebody in charge
knew that this was happening,
because that's not supposed
to be the way it goes.
20 minutes later, they
were still believing
that this thing was an agent.
It was still out to get them.
They made eye contact with
it, they thought it was more
intelligent than the
others, they thought it was
more interesting to play with
and had better strategies.
It was better looking
than the other robots.
I still don't understand that one.
But everything for them changed.
And what was really hard
is that it didn't stop.
All of our other motion-based
techniques for generating
agency and animacy,
they're the kinds of things
we can turn on and turn off so easily.
This one wasn't.
It was very hard for
us to get them to stop.
What's even more interesting
is that this is very specific
to it stealing your victory.
If in fact the robot cheats,
but cheats in your favor,
if it gives you a victory
you don't deserve,
you could care less.
It's not an agent; that
was just a malfunction.
You're just lucky.
In fact, here's a different
robot doing that same thing.
When the robot cheats in order to lose,
throws you a victory.
- [Robot] Let's play.
- We get confusion, we get uncertainty.
- [Robot] Oh, you win.
Let's play.
Oh, you win.
- But when that robot
steals your victory...
- [Robot] Yes, I win.
Let's play.
- No, you can't do that.
- You are not ready to put up with that.
- What?!
- I win.
- You cheated!
You cheated now.
- I win.
- Hey, you big cheater!
You cheat, super cheat!
(laughing)
- I have so many hours
of Yale undergraduates
swearing at robots, you
would not believe it.
So, ah, so let me say
this just at the end.
One of the things that's
really unique about these
is robots let us investigate things
about that frontier, about that boundary,
that we couldn't investigate with people.
It's hard for me to
produce for you a person
with no lower eyelid.
It's hard for me to produce
a person that you're willing
to sit and play this game against,
where you're uncertain what
their agency status is.
But we can do that with the robot.
And we can uncover things.
Now, as a very last thing,
I can ask the question:
why is it important?
Why do I need to know what
that boundary is like?
Why should I care about that?
Well, one of the real interesting things
is that no matter what we end up doing,
those unique parts of the boundary
are often where we find
the most interesting
and exciting applications
for these robots.
I told you before that
you are more compliant
with a physical robot
than other technology,
you'll learn faster with a physical robot.
That's one of the reasons we
use robots for tutoring now.
In fact, last year, we
started doing in-home tutoring
for kids with autism, with
a little robot platform.
And the kids would sit and
play social skills games
with these robots.
They would play the same kinds of games
that they would in therapy,
and they did them in the really complex
and difficult environment of the home.
And I don't have a ton
of time to talk about it,
so I'm gonna skip past and just say,
let's let one of the
parents who've done this,
actually say something about it.
- He is so excited to
spend his half an hour
helping the robot find his way home,
and he will come on, and
I will set it up for him,
turn on the robot, and he
is engaged immediately.
Having the ability to have this robot
and to do an hour of therapy with him,
that was really specific to
what he needs to focus on
was just, it seemed like a
great opportunity for him.
It's really been just, he's
been engaged and intrigued,
and sometimes therapies are,
they get a little exhausting
and he's not excited, and
this one wasn't like that.
He was ready to play
at 7:30 in the morning.
It's that, we went to
the playground one day,
and I noticed immediately
there was a group of children
playing in the sand, and he
walked up to them and said:
hi, what are you doing?
And I don't think he would
have done that a month ago.
- This family in particular,
even though with all
of our families we saw kids
make clinically verified skill
improvements, the first
time a piece of technology
has done that, where we saw
kids not only try to avoid
their therapy or skate by,
but actively engaging with it.
We saw the parents being thrilled with it,
we saw the skills start to
bleed over to the playground.
This family, they found out
midway through that month
that they had that robot,
the husband got a new job,
got transferred to the west coast,
they were supposed to move right away.
They shipped all of their
stuff out of their house.
That's why all of those shelves are bare.
And they decided for the last three weeks,
they were gonna sleep in
sleeping bags on the floor
so they could stay with the robot,
because of how much that
was meaning to their son.
That's what we get when
we start to characterize
this boundary.
We get systems where we really
can make an impact on people.
All right, let me end
just by saying thanks
to a whole lot of people.
If you want any other
information, our website's there,
and I'm happy to take questions
until you're tired of us.
So thank you.
(applauding)
Go ahead.
(unintelligible muttering)
Yeah.
(muttering)
Oh wait, they want you on.
- [Attendee] So my observation
is I'm a lot less patient
with my virtual assistants
than I am with real people.
- Yes, ah, and it's
interesting because one
of the things that we see
with real, physical robots,
is that people are much
more willing to adjust
when the robots make mistakes.
And I don't know if that's
an embodiment effect
that carries over or not,
but we see it all the time.
We build systems that do
manufacturing with people.
So side by side, you're building
a birdhouse with the robot.
And in fact, when the
robot makes a mistake
and drops a tool, they
don't get mad at the robot.
They help it out.
We see that happen over and over again.
- [Attendee] Thanks very
much for an interesting talk.
So on the very last work
with the autistic child,
it's unethical but I'll ask anyway,
was there a controlled
experiment where the robot
was on a screen instead of in person?
- Yeah, we don't do a control
there because we know,
in fact, that these kids will not learn
from things on the screen.
We've had a couple of other
studies that predate that,
that show it.
What we do use as a control
though, is we track the children
the month before they get the robot,
then a month with the robot,
and then a month after
the robot has gone away.
And in fact, those kids,
I'm sure I can just
show you the data,
that's the easiest thing.
Those kids in the month
before the robot shows up,
they show no difference
in the social skills
that we measure.
A month with the robot and
they start showing improvement.
But you take the robot away,
and that improvement starts to fade away.
Now, that's not, in fact, unusual,
and that's in fact what we expect to see.
Because a month with a personal therapist,
sitting in your home,
100 percent of the time,
you don't get lasting
effects after just a month.
So if we had gotten that with the robot,
something would have been wrong.
So, we know that that's
actually sort of exactly
the pattern that we wanted to see, sure.
- [Attendee] In the
case of the robot making
facial expressions that frightened
away some of the students
did those students recognize immediately
that the reason they were frightened was
because it was missing a lower eyelid?
- No, so they couldn't tell us that.
And that was really what was,
in part, really interesting.
The could tell us what they thought.
They thought the robot was aggressive,
they thought the robot was angry, okay?
But they couldn't pinpoint
exactly why that was.
That took a little bit of
experiment on our part,
in order to figure that out,
and it actually took
us a couple of months.
So don't feel bad that
you missed the eyelid.
You know, we put that thing together,
and it still took us
months to figure it out.
Yeah.
- [Attendee] Thank you so
much for this wonderful talk.
I wonder if there are
studies about interactions
between children and toys and whether toys
are kind of an intermediate
agent between humans and robots?
- Yeah, and you have to now
talk about different ages
of children, as well, and in fact,
one of the really interesting
things that you see
is you see young kids
who are willing to take,
let's say, a stuffed doll
and to have a pretend
relationship with that doll, or for them,
what is probably a real relationship,
but with this character that
does not reciprocate in any way
and you introduce a thing with technology
that does have that kind of interactivity,
and that relationship
becomes even stronger.
We've seen these kinds of things
with robots being developed
for kindergarten.
We've even done experiments
with, ah, robots with kids
as young as six-month old, deaf infants,
learning sign language from robots.
So we've seen this very, very early on.
There are similarities to the
way that they engage with toys
but also some things that are different,
based on the age appropriateness.
It's a really good
question that we don't know
enough about, though, yeah.
- [Attendee] Brian, thank
you, that was brilliant.
- Oh, thank you.
- [Attendee] I'm thinking
of the difference
between a robot and human,
and robot and human-controlled robot.
In the context of the
books and the trash can.
Would you say, what do
you think about that?
If the robot were to be human-controlled,
or if they had a human
telling them: throw it away.
- Yeah, so in many of these cases,
whether you perceive that
the robot is autonomous
does in fact make a difference.
So if I know, if I'm told there's a person
who's controlling this
system in the other room--
(muttering)
No, no, go ahead.
- [Attendee] If you're no
told that there's a human.
- Right, so if I am told,
then there's a response,
and I treat the robot like it's a person.
Because I know that it's a
person making the decision.
If I'm not told then I have to
make this uncertain judgment.
Sometimes people do think that
there's a human in control,
when in fact it's not,
and sometimes in fact,
people will do the exact opposite.
That is, they'll think it's
autonomous when in fact,
there is a human in control.
One of the common methods
that we use in this field
is a prototype study called
a Wizard of Oz study.
In which the robot is
being secretly controlled
by a human in the other room,
but you're not told that,
and we in fact provoke the
illusion that there is,
in fact, full autonomy with the robot,
even though there is this secret
wizard behind the curtain.
And we do that as a prototyping
device often because
the cost of developing that
autonomy within the robot
is substantial, and if we just want to see
what the effect would be,
we'll pretend in this way.
We ran one study, in fact,
where there was a robot
on a table, and I was standing
next to the participant,
and I had a clipboard.
And in fact, I was controlling
the robot the entire time,
because taped to the
bottom of the clipboard
was a television remote,
where I could push
different buttons on the remote
and get the robot to behave.
We ran that protocol with
over 300 Yale undergraduates.
Not one of them ever picked up on the fact
that I was running the
robot right next to them.
When we see these systems
and when we're designing
them properly, you want to believe.
It's not even that we do a good job.
I'd like to think we do a good job,
but you want to believe
that it's autonomous.
So in fact, that's
almost our default case.
- [Attendee] I was wondering,
in the conformity experiment
with Dixit, if you had one
group that had a person
giving the clue, and then
robots following afterwards
with a similar but different
answer than the other human?
- Yeah, so we didn't do that.
We did a pilot version of
that with the Dixit study.
It didn't matter if it was
a human giving the word
or a robot giving the word,
it didn't seem to matter.
There are some cases where
when we substitute a human
in for the robot, it
does make a difference.
If you remember that
study about the effect
of embodiment on learning
games, with the nonograms,
that sort of Sudoku-like puzzle,
and I told you if you have
the robot sitting next to you,
you improve by six minutes.
Well, one of the things
we don't like to report
is we actually ran a fifth
version of that protocol,
where instead of getting
those clues from a robot
sitting next to you, we had
a human sitting next to you,
giving you those clues.
Okay, so here's the time
when everybody gets to guess.
If no clues you improved by two minutes,
two clues, you get clues but
you get them from the video,
or just audio, you
improve by four minutes,
with the robot, you
improve by six minutes.
How much do you improve
if you have a human there?
(muttering)
None?
Eight minutes?
- [Attendee] It's worse?
- Four, six?
Okay, the actual answer is minus five.
(laughing)
People, in fact, get worse,
the longer we leave them there.
Okay?
And in fact, this is easy to understand.
That I'll give you this option.
Would you like to take the exam in a room
all by yourself, or would
you like to take the exam,
sitting in my office while I
stare at you the whole time?
(laughing)
I don't know anybody who's
gonna take the staring, right?
When we sat a person there,
and even though they were
giving them these helpful clues,
people got nervous.
And in fact, their performance
basically kept degrading
over time.
So there are some cases
where we don't report
the human version, in
fact, because it makes such
a difference that it doesn't, you know,
there is, it's not really comparable.
But most of the time, we
do try a human variant,
and when it doesn't make any difference,
we just usually don't report it.
- [Attendee] Hi, so starting
from this last answer
you gave in this fifth try, it seems to me
that this frontier, right,
that shifts very much,
not only depending on
what's on the other side,
but also on the humans on
the, let's say on our side.
So if you have people that
have been growing up in Japan,
something looks, but if you have, ah,
and if you have Yale undergrads,
they probably behave in a,
so, so what I don't understand
is what you call a frontier,
it seems to me like a very,
variable, depending not only
on what's on the computer,
or the machine on the
other side, but also who's,
you know, I'm from Italy
and I was thinking:
how would Italians react
to a computer cheating?
- Yeah.
- [Attendee] Right, because
we have a different cultural
understanding of what is cheating,
so you know, how generalizable
are these findings?
This is my question.
- Yeah, so I can give
you two answers to this.
One is, we do know that
there are cultural effects,
and age-related effects especially,
that impact this boundary.
And to some extent, we're okay with that.
The idea that I have
different cultural boundaries
that determine my perceptions,
that's, I would expect that.
The idea that my perceptions
change between when I'm three
years old and seven
years old and an adult?
I'm willing to accept that.
That's a standard part
of the way we think about
the way we perceive the world.
And so the fact that this
technology has this shifting
boundary that's also
culturally determined,
that I think is something that I think
everyone in this field
would fully acknowledge.
In terms of how repeatable
or how universal
are these things, that's one of the things
that when we find them,
when we find those ones
that are universal, that
hold up across a wide range
of circumstances, across
a wide range of cultures,
across a range of ages, that's when things
get to be really interesting.
Some of these studies do
that, and some of them don't.
For example, those conformity studies,
the really simple one, the Asch studies
with the matching the line lengths?
In fact, if you do that with
robots and five year olds,
and Tony Belpaeme has done this in the UK,
the five year olds go
along with the robots.
In fact, about two thirds of the time,
they will change their answer
to go along with the robots.
Adults won't do it, but kids will.
For adults, we have to make
it slightly more subtle,
in order for them to buy into it.
Are there cultural differences
across that conformity effect?
Yeah, in fact, the Asch studies
have seen large cultural
variations in human to human
effects of peer influence.
So that's where we would
expect to see variations
in robot influence on them as well.
There are other studies, though,
that seem to be universal.
That compliance result,
about throwing away things
in the trash can, we've had groups,
I think I'm up to counting
somewhere around 35 groups
all over the US, Asia,
Europe, South America.
I don't think we have
any out of Africa yet,
but here we see lots
of different cultures,
all of them showing the same result.
That's when we start seeing
something and saying:
maybe this is something fundamental.
And so in fact, mapping
these not only in terms
of just is there, where is the boundary?
But when does the boundary shift?
Does it vary based on age,
does it vary based on culture?
That's part of the interesting data to us.
I hope that answered your question.
- [Attendee] A question about
the anthropomorphism aspect
of the whole thing: we know,
for example, from the way
people treat different
kinds of animals as pets,
there are the fuzzy ones
and then there's frogs
and so on that we care less about.
Are there controls that
sort of take, I mean,
you said one of your robots
had four eyes, or four cameras,
I've already agreed that
they're eyes, right?
- Right.
- [Attendee] But the
empathy we have for things
that look like us versus other, I mean,
do you have a control with a robot
that looks like a mollusc or something?
- Yeah, so, there are
some things where, ah,
you know, many of these
things, you have to realize,
this is a field that's about 10 years old.
And the number of things
that have been done
exhaustively is very small.
But there are many places
where we do see a range
of different kinds of robots being used.
And I didn't have this slide
up here, but for example,
when we do work with children
with ASD, with autism,
one of the things we wonder about is:
what's the range of robots
where we see these effects?
And so we see some robots
developed that look like,
more like people or more
like dolls or more like pets,
or more like, you know, mechanical,
what robots are supposed
to look like, right?
And we see this variety
and then we start thinking
maybe it's not something
about the appearance.
And then what's really
compelling is when we see
somebody do it with something
that's really abstract.
There's a group in Canada
that does these studies
with kids with ASD with
robot that is literally
just a sphere; there's no
markings on the outside of it,
it's literally a ball.
And yet it rolls around on the floor
and it changes direction,
and it responds to the child,
and they get the same
kind of learning effects.
And that's the point at
which we say maybe it's,
it's really hard to think
that it has something
to do with appearance when you can do it
with these geometric
shapes that have nothing
anthropomorphic about them.
So, these aren't proof, in
the way that we would like
to be able to say, definitively,
appearance doesn't matter,
or appearance does matter.
But what we have at this point
is a sampling, in that space.
(muttering)
Yes, yeah, and--
Exactly, and so one of the questions is:
what are the minimal sets of behavior
that you need in order to
generate these responses?
And we're roboticists, and
so everything we do costs us.
In terms of time and energy.
And so we are naturally minimalists.
We want to get the minimal set of things
to provoke a response.
And that's why we deal, usually,
with things that are
very simplified in form.
- [Priya] So I'm gonna take
the privilege of asking
you the last question before we wrap up,
and I just want to point
out, we have a nice reception
outside where we can
continue the conversation.
So Brian, I was very curious
with these experiments
whether there was a
notion of added expertise,
authority, that is
conferred on these robots,
as opposed to sort of
human-controlled robots,
versus just humans?
Is that an effect that you guys look at?
I mean, can robots get humans
to follow orders better
than humans can get other
humans to, for instance?
- So it's hard to do a
comparison with robots as,
you know, sort of giving
instructions versus humans
as giving instructions,
because they are different.
And if I had someone who was, you know,
who could take on a social status
that was as uncertain as the robot's,
then maybe that would be
possible for me to measure.
But there are a lot of studies
that we've been able to do
where we number one show
that people will follow
those robots when they give instructions,
and in fact, that we can use those robots
to very subtly manipulate people.
And in fact, it's sometimes
more the very minute things
that matter, much more
than the overt framing.
And let me give you a very
quick example, a last story.
We ran a protocol where we
brought two people into the lab,
and we told them that
they were gonna take turns
playing a game with a robot; Connect Four.
Okay, a little like,
tic-tac-toe like game.
And secretly, one of those two people
was a confederate and was working for me.
And I said, okay, to the confederate,
you're gonna play first.
While you're playing, the other
person's gonna keep score.
And so the confederate would
start playing the game,
and about halfway through the game,
I called their cellphone and they said:
oh, I'm sorry, this is my
dean, I've got to answer this.
I'll be right back,
and they left the room.
And while they were gone, the
robot picked up an extra piece
and put it in, and picked up
an extra piece and put it in,
and picked up an extra
piece and put it in.
Cheated, effectively.
The confederate walks back into the room,
and the question is: does
the scorekeeper report
that the robot had done this?
So first, do they spontaneously do it?
Almost none of them
spontaneously report it.
The confederate then asks:
did something weird happen?
It looks like something's
different at the board.
And keeps asking them
question after question
until finally it asks
them: did the robot cheat?
Did the robot put in more pieces?
And about 50 percent
of our undergraduates,
at that point, will say: no.
They'll lie right through their teeth.
(laughing)
Okay?
Now here's the subtle part.
If we bring in another group,
the confederate's phone rings,
they leave the room, the
robot picks up a piece,
looks at it, and then it
looks a you, and puts it in.
Picks up another piece
and it looks at you,
and it puts it in.
And now the confederate comes back in,
and now about 75 percent
of our undergraduates lie.
(laughing)
And as a last and final
one, a third group comes in,
the confederate, we call their phone,
they leave the room, the
robot picks up a piece,
and it looks at you, and it goes...
(laughing)
And it drops it in and
it does the same thing.
And we have never had an
undergraduate tell the truth,
in that situation.
Every single one of the, I don't know,
100 or so we've tested
has lied, at that point.
And it's not just that they lie.
They have to lie multiple times.
Because the confederate
comes back in and says:
did something weird happen?
No.
Did the board change.
Did the robot do something.
No.
Over and over again.
Sometimes we don't need the big framing.
Sometimes it's those little
bits of social influence
that actually make much
more of a difference.
And so that's why we
don't often do these sort
of high level comparisons,
because it's really
in the details that it matters.
- [Attendee] Did you ask them why?
- Oh, yeah, and they, I mean,
some of them will actually go as far as
they won't tell us afterwards.
They will continue to
lie to us afterwards,
even though after we explain it to them,
we say: we know the robot did this.
They'll say: no!
Some of them are just so
entrenched in the idea of:
I'm not gonna tell.
- [Priya] Thank you so much, Brian,
for a scintillating talk.
- Thank you.
(applauding)
(tranquil music)